another sex scandal is about to rock
westminster scotland yard have confirmed
to sky news
that an mp has been arrested and remains
in custody uh for following a number of
sex allegations conservative whips have
confirmed to sky news it is a
conservative mp let me read you first of
all the statement from scotland yard to
sky news in the last couple of minutes
in january 2020 the met received a
report relating to alleged sexual
offenses having been committed between
2002
and 2009. the offences are alleged to
have occurred in london an investigation
is ongoing led by officers from central
specialist crime a man aged in his 50s
was arrested on suspicion of indecent
assault sexual assault
rape
abuse of position of trust and
misconduct in public office he remains
in custody now the fact that those
offences or allegations include
abuse of position of trust and
misconduct in a public office suggests
that the victim or complainant may well
be
a member of staff or an aide employed by
a member of parliament confirmation that
it's a conservative comes from the
government whips office which has told
sky news
the chief whip has asked that the mp
concerned does not attend the
parliamentary estate while an
investigation is ongoing until the
conclusion of the investigation we will
not be commenting further well that the
chief whip is now chris heaton harris
appointed just a few weeks ago um he has
asked that the mp concern does not
attend the parliamentary state obviously
a busy time in parliament day five of
the queen speech debate votes tonight
votes tomorrow
until while the investigation's ongoing
now the police are saying uh that the
person remain man remains in custody
this is the latest uh allegation sex
scandal call it what you will to rock
westminster only a few weeks ago imran
ahmad khan mp for
wakefield in west yorkshire resigned as
a conservative mp he was convicted of
sexual assault against a 15 year old boy
there have been allegations of sexual
harassment against another conservative
backbencher and then a couple of weeks
ago there was reported that there are
around 50 mps including some front
benchers believed to have been referred
to the parliamentary authorities over
sex assault claims you remember the pest
minster so-called pest minister scandal
a few uh
years ago it may well be that this is
linked to that given that the police
statement says uh that they received a
report in january 2020
and they've carried out a two-year
investigation
um the metropolitan police have let it
be known that they they don't identify
people or anyone who may or may not be
subject to an investigation and um
being given this statement uh is not
confirmation of any name or profession
media may attribute or wish to attribute
um it's been given on the basis of being
requested for information on the
incidents a time frame they occurred and
when reported to police um the met is
also letting it be known that should the
media attribute a name or profession to
the victim or the person under
investigation that will this will not
have been confirmed
by the metropolitan police but just to
reaffirm and confirm
another sex scandal is about to rock
westminster uh because news is breaking
here that an mp we know to be a
conservative that's confirmed by
conservative whips has been arrested uh
for rape and other offences sexual
assault abuse of uh
abusive position of trust misconduct in
a public office that person remains in
custody all this while parliament is uh
busy on the
debating the cost of living the liz
trust statement on the northern ireland
protocol this will send shockwaves
through westminster
hugely serious allegations about an mp a
serving mp uh but the
the allegations relate to quite a few
years back 2002 to 2009
john craig uh thanks uh so much for that
uh and as john was saying remains in
custody so no
further information yet as to their
identity more to come when we get it